تتصفح أمريكا الآن باستخدام المتصفحات
، حيث تتسوق النوافذ مع نوافذ كبار
تجار التجزئة على شبكة الإنترنت بشكل كبير
من Macy's و Penny's وجميع
الأسماء المنزلية الأخرى التي يمتلكها الأشخاص
بالفعل علاقة مع
macys.com والتي تم إطلاقها هذا العام
بربع  مليون قطعة
تضعها أزياء الأشياء الكبيرة على موقع الويب في منشأة IBM هذه
في أتلانتا والصين يتم شحنها
من هذا المستودع في سكرامنتو ، حيث
يتم تغليف البضائع للشحنات
ونحصل على طلباتهم في غضون 24 ساعة ،
يذهب بعض المصنّعين مباشرة إلى
المستهلك هل تعلم هناك  كانت
مئات الأنواع والأنماط المختلفة من
Levi's و Dockers ، يمكنك الانتقال
من الصفحة الأولى إلى شراء منتج في
غضون ثلاث نقرات جيدًا
يمكنهم تصفحها وهناك أيضًا
غرفة تغيير الملابس حتى يتمكنوا من التسوق
والقمم المختلفة والكاكي على الشاشة
قم بخلط وتطابق الإرشادات الخاصة
بمتصفح الويب الذي يعاني من ضعف في الأسلوب ومخطط لمساعدة
النساء فعليًا على تجربة تلك السيدة الجديدة التي
يضعها الكاكي ببساطة في  قياسات
في الطول الخاص بك ويعيد الخرائط إلى
حجمنا ويقدم أفضل
توصية ل Dockers khakis و
Dockers قمم نحن أكثر سهولة في التسوق
عبر الويب ، يقول أحد الاستطلاعات إن 43 بالمائة من
مستخدمي الكمبيوتر سيشترون عبر الإنترنت هذا
الموسم تضاعف ثلاث مرات عدد العام الماضي
شراكتنا مع شركة IBM ، وضعنا أفضل
تقنية أمان متاحة هناك
ما يقرب من 3000 شركة تظهر على
موقع تسوق Yahoo ، يأتي معظم الناس
بفئة عامة وأتطلع
لشراء نوادي الجولف والدي وأنا أتطلع
لشراء عجلات ساخنة لأطفالي  تم بيع اللعبة رقم واحد
في كل مكان ولكن
على الويب ، ولكن ما حدث هو أن هناك
عددًا كبيرًا جدًا يقترب من
ألف نحلة من الفراء تظهر على موقع Yahoo في
قسم المزاد ، التسوق الجديد ونافذة التصفح
Craig LaFave CNN San Francisco
[  موسيقى]